risk-risk-reward. So what do I mean by risk-reward? If you risk one to win two, that would be a 2R
risk-reward ratio. So let's look at how this plays out.
So if you have a 50% win rate and you make two times as much as you risk per trade,
and you're risking 10%, this is what you're kind of P&L.
You're gonna have drawdown, but you're gonna bounce back. As you guys saw today,
I was able to take losses and then bounce back.
It's because of my risk-reward ratio. A 1 to 1 means that you risk 100 to make 100.
You can't bounce back. You don't have enough bounce back, and that's a 50% win rate.
You'll just slowly bleed out. So if you have a 50% win rate and you're using a 1 to 1
risk-reward ratio, you have an 84% chance of blowing up. If you have a 40% win rate and 1 to 1,
you have 100%. This is why I laugh at those dudes pushing low risk-to-reward strategies.
They don't work. It may have short-term success, but it won't work long-term.
If you have a 2 to 1, meaning you make more than double what you lose,
you only have a 4% chance. Look at that.
They're gonna tell you that this is the way to go when you look at something like that.
If you have a 1 to 1 and you have an 80% win rate, that's a different story.
I think 55% to 60%. I think that's about where it should be.
Well, you'll see here by adjusting your position sizing and risking only 5%,
you can have a... it lowers your chances of blowing up by quite a bit.
It removes it to 50%. And then if you have a 2 to 1 and a 60%, 0% chance of blowing up,
because the amount of losses you would need to take in a row, it's just unlikely to happen.
This here looks at probability of losing trades in a row.
I know we all like to think that the law of large numbers doesn't apply to us,
but it does. Trust me, it does.
It will play out no matter what you do.
It's just like it's the world we live in for whatever reason it plays out.
I can't tell you why, but if you have a win rate of 55%, which is really good,
you have a 100% chance of taking three losses in a row.
98% for losses in a row. That means that if you risk $500,
let's say, you could only take four losses before you blow up
and you have a 98% chance of doing that.
So if you're failed automatically, risking too much,
you're going to blow up no matter what you do.
So this is why you have to stick to 10% or less of your total drawdown.
If you don't do that, you're going to fail no matter what you do.
Even a 75% win rate, you still have a 32% chance of hitting four losses in a row.
So if you had a 75% win rate and you're risking $500 per trade,
32% of the time, you're going to blow up without anything else,
all the other stuff that makes it harder to trade to death
because of commissions and everything else.
Probably use this for another video.
Let's just go over real quick already here.
So how to correct common trading failures.
So failure to accept randomness.
I think that's one of the biggest issues with traders.
Outcomes are random.
This is a law.
Approach our edge as a large set of trades.
Don't assess on a single trade or two.
Understand that this is the law and it does apply to your trading.
Even though we may know where the market goes,
even though we may understand the market,
but our strategies have a win rate baked into them
and that win rate is going to play out over a set of large numbers.
Look at your setups as you don't know which ones are going to be wins and losses,
but out of a set of 10 trades, you're going to win five to six of them.
You don't know when the four losses are going to come,
but you understand that they are going to come at some point.
Whether they're in a row or they're spread out, you don't know.
This removes the, you shouldn't be upset about taking a loss then
because it's baked into your strategy.
It's a given.
Losses are going to come.
It removes the, you shouldn't really get upset about it.
It sucks, but you don't need to be upset about it
because as long as you're following the process, it will play out in your favor.
Failure to accept losses are necessary.
We are placing a bet to see if our variables are correct
and the stop loss keeps us in business.
Failure to honor our risk limits.
Sometimes things simply don't work.
Respecting loss limits like understanding today is a red day
and just eating it and not continuing to blow up all the work you put in place.
Failure to use leverage correctly.
We just talked about that failure to track performance.
There is no professional anything that doesn't understand their statistics.
Every business understands their profit and loss.
Every business understands their expenses.
Every business and you have to treat trading the same way.
You must look at your stats.
Some basic expectations and beliefs we must embrace to succeed.
This is really important guys.
Trade process versus outcomes.
Judge what I do rather than money gained or lost.
While I do like this statement, I don't want to sit here
and tell you money doesn't matter because that's a bunch of guru BS.
We should be focused on process and understand that over a set of trades,
we will make the money.
But I hate when people say just don't worry about the money.
It will come.
What do you mean?
I think that is a weird statement to make
because we are risking money to make more money.
That's trading.
Trading is risking money, putting money at risk
to then make more money.
That's trading.
So I think disassociating the money from the trading I don't think is good,
but you need to focus on the process that will then lead to the money.
Judge on large numbers.
The last trade doesn't matter.
You need a lot of trades for your edge to fully play out.
Growth mindset, very important.
Always adapting and continuing to learn and get better.
Number four, basic expectation and randomness is inevitable.
Anything can happen.
This just means accepting a loss because it is the randomness built into your strategy.
I'm not saying the markets are random.
I'm not saying that I'm saying the strategies when winning losses,
the best way to look at them is that over a set of trades,
you're going to win five to six of them,
but you're going to lose four of them.
The randomness is the four losses.
You don't know when they're going to come.
That's randomness.
Limit stops and restraints.
Limit bet size so we can stay in the game.
If you're over risking, you're not going to be able to stay in the game,
and if you're not accepting a red day and you continue to push,
you're not going to stay in the game.
So next, number six, I am a professional.
I track what I'm doing and what works or doesn't work.
Again, there are no professionals in any field that don't do this.
So trading is no different.
These are things that you must do as a trader and accept.
This is the bare minimum, guys.
So if you're not tracking, you're not looking at your statistics
at the end of the day or at the end of the week,
if you're just not looking at them all,
you're not doing what's required of you.
And until you do it, you should expect to fail.
Let me say that again.
If you're not doing and looking and believing
what's on this list here and you're failing
until you implement these beliefs and bare minimums,
you will continue to fail.
So if you're not doing it, aware of your statistics
and you're not in some type of way tracking
what's working for you or doesn't,
you will continue to fail until you make that change.
The market is not out to get me.
This is a big one.
No one is trying to run your stops.
You're just simply in the way of the market at that moment.
Stop looking at the market at a negative light.
Trade setups must show themselves.
Don't project your view onto the markets.
You saw me do this yesterday.
Didn't work out very well for me, right?
I failed because I refused to accept number eight.
I refused to accept that the market was bullish.
I was projecting my view onto the market
and it resulted in failure.
So here's some other things.
Failure to define our edge.
Have a theory and test it.
Know why the market should pay us.
Write down the context necessary to take a trade.
That's like a Saturday study session.
If you do that with me.
Failure to prepare.
Saturday study session.
Sunday prep.
Failure to follow a process.
This is probably one of the biggest ones.
Define and follow the process that gets us into a trade.
And I'm actually going to have a call with someone,
probably here in a little bit,
one of the people in the group and just help them
because I think they're almost all the way there.
I just don't think they're following the process.
So this is what I mean by lowering the entropy,
the randomness.
You must have know what to do, when to do it,
how to do it and already have that all predefined.
If there's a bunch of randomness in your trading,
you're going to fail.
And that means you have to follow a process.
Failure to wait.
Failure to stay focused.
Pretty self-explanatory.
So everything that we talked about
leads to these five truths to be profitable.
I want to make this clear, guys.
This right here is your key to profitability
and fast-tracking it and getting profitable now.
Next week, not a month, not a year.
Now, I have spent so much time honing this in
as you saw Captain Kirk asking about
a old risk to reward ratio I used to use.
So I have been honing these five rules
of trading management and they're so well honed in now
that you can be, it sounds dumb to even say out loud,
a 11% win rate without counting commissions.
You will be break even.
You will just tread water, which is crazy.
If you follow this to the tee.
With that said, all you need is a 33% win rate.
Remember flipping a quarter is 50%.
That means if you were just to randomly
enter into the market at random
and implement this, you would be profitable.
A 33% win rate, that means that all you have to win
is four out of the 10 trades.
If you take 10 trades a day,
all you have to do is win four of them,
which is worse than entering in randomly.
And with my strategies that I've already taught you guys
or you're learning, you're good to go.
But I will say one thing about this.
You have to understand where price is
redelivering for this to work because the target
is dependent on redelivery.
If you don't understand where price must redeliver to,
you can take everything I just said
and it's not going to work
because you're not going to be able to get to our wins
without that.
That's why I make that clear.
I don't want to make it sound like it's some all in be all
because there is a requirements and it's hard to follow
because it's a process
and it goes against our human nature
and you do need to understand redelivery.
So here is how you do it.
Now named to ATM because it's essentially what it is.
You guys see it, it works, right?
So number one, you need to enter in
with an even number of contracts,
whether it's two, four, six, eight, 10,
or as close as that as you can get to.
So if you buy into the market right here,
you buy here, your stop loss is here,
you're going to scale out and exit half your position.
We're going to measure this here, how many points this is.
If you're risking 10 points,
that means at 13 points,
you're going to take off half of your position.
You're going to exit half here at the market.
When price gets here, you're just going to exit.
So if you had six micros on, you're going to exit three.
And now by doing this, that removes all risk.
You're no longer having your risk in the trade.
You cannot lose because if you exit at half here,
up here, you had $200 of profit.
You had $150 of risk.
Let's say you had $150 of risk on the trade
that if you got stopped out, you would lose $150.
Up here, you have $200 profit.
With two contracts, you had $200 of profit.
You would now have banked and put that $100 and guaranteed it.
And now you only have $75 of risk remaining,
but you just got $100.
So that means you'll make $25,
even if price comes back down and all the way back down here
and stops you out, you are not to move your stop loss.
Do not move it to here.
Do not move it to break even.
That ruins it.
People talk about moving your stop to break even.
It is in this trade management style.
It is a very bad thing.
It causes it.
You won't be profitable.
That was rule three, leave stop.
And then, so this is 1.3 times the risk, right?
So now you're going to find a area
that needs to be re-delivered to that is two times.
So if your risk was 10,
the 2R target needs to be at least 20 points away.
So once price gets to your target,
you're not going to set a limit order.
You're going to implement one time framing on the one minute.
So once price gets up here,
you scale out there, it gets to your target.
You're not going to exit here,
but you're going to implement one time framing.
So as long as price does not close below the previous candle,
you stay in the trade.
I don't care if it goes for another 500 points.
You stay in it no matter what.
And then when it finally closes below the previous candle is low,
you get out.
I mean, when that happens, you get out.
But you do not do it early
because you're not a weak person.
Weak people do that
because they're scared of giving back profits.
They're scared of giving back money
that's being made for them automatically
without them doing anything else.
So then let's say this is a winning trade,
you would then risk 10, you made 60.
Exiting here would have got you 20.
So you get extra 40 points of profit.
And then not every trade is going to work out like that.
But over a set of, let's say, 10 trades,
usually two of them will.
So one of them you might even give back a little bit here
when you go to, maybe it starts one time frame
and the next candle's big down.
And then instead of getting a 2R, you get 1.7, whatever.
The big trades, as you saw this morning,
I got extra 200 points or something like that
by using one time framing.
200 points, that's crazy, right?
But that's it.
By doing this, you can do this, guys.
But you can go your own way and figure it out yourself.
Let's hear your prerogative.
But I have done my part.
I've done everything I can to try to help you figure this out.
Obviously, I'll keep trying to help you.
But if you want this, you just got to,
are you willing to do it or not?
It's not going to feel good.
You're not going to like it.
It's not going to make you happy in the moment.
But quitting your job, retiring your fucking parents,
moving into your dream house,
whatever your goal is and why you're doing this,
quitting whatever it is, is worth it, right?
So is doing this worth that?
Absolutely.
So we just got to do it, guys.
You don't have to.
Obviously, you can go your own route
and figure it out yourself.
But I'm giving you a cheat code here
that took me so long to figure out and hone in.
It seems like an easy thing to do and figure out.
But it's really not.
Because no one else in the whole fucking world
was telling me to do it this way.
Everybody in the game was telling me to do it the opposite way.
Every single person.
And that's what took it so long
is because I had to look at what they told me to do
and then try it, realize it doesn't work.
Why doesn't it work?
Because they're not traders.
They're gurus.
They're affiliates that aren't even trading.
So they're giving me advice on something they don't even do.
And it really wasn't until I found a real trader,
which was FuturesTrader72.
And he talked about scaling out.
And he showed the math
and how it actually makes trades better.
Even though you're getting less money on that first contract,
it improves the overall mathematics of profitable trading.
It wasn't until I saw that
where I really started to think about trading differently.
But I'll tell you right now,
no one else is going to tell you to do it this way.
They're going to tell you to do it the exact opposite way,
which if you want to do it that way, it's fine.
But I'm giving you a key here that I would try.
What's the worst that can happen?
The next three evals you buy,
you do your hardest to do this.
Let's say on one of our three of them,
you're actually able to follow the process to the T
and you don't deviate from it.
And then you get a payout.
That's the worst that can happen.
But it's not going to be easy.
It's not easy because the greed sets in when the trade starts.
You don't want to exit at 1.3 R.
You don't want to take off half your profit at the moment
because of greed.
Even though it guarantees a winner
and you still get the upside,
but in the moment, you have to fight the greed.
And then the fear sets in as price,
maybe bouncing around your breakeven price.
You want to move your stop to breakeven.
So you have to fight the fear.
And then if the trade does go your way,
you have to fight the fear of giving back profits
all the way to 2R.
And then once at 2R,
you have to fight the fear even more
and allow one time for him to play out.
And everything in your body and your mind
is going to be telling you to exit.
But that is not the right thing to do.
I think good trading, you should be uncomfortable.
It's going to be uncomfortable.
If it was comfortable and easy and fun,
there would be no money in it.
Go work a night.
It'd be like a nine to five.
It's easy to show up to your job every day.
It's easy to do it.
You're comfortable with doing it
because you've been doing it forever.
But I'm just letting you know
it's not going to be easy to do.
But if you do do it,
I don't want to sound like a guru here
and say I guarantee you'll be profitable.
But unless you're going into tilt and over-risking
and doing something stupid,
it will be, I should have put here,
let me make a,
it just needs to be stated here.
10% drawdown per trade.
Whatever it is, that's a must.
Because if you're risking,
if you got $2,000 of drawdown
and you're risking a thousand,
this isn't going to help you, right?
So in a 50K account, that would be max $200.
I would say you could get away with 12.5%.
But that's about it.
All right, guys, I think that will do it.
I urge you, I beg you, just do it.
I want to see you guys win.
I want to see you be successful.
So if you won't, just try it.
For fuck's sake, please, not half-ass,
but really do it and see if it works.
Call me out, test it.
If you don't think it's worth it, why?
If you're not willing to try it, why?
You don't think it's real?
Prove me wrong, show me.
If you're unwilling to do it
because you just don't have the mindset
and you're just not, then quit right now.
You're in the wrong, you're not built for this.
All righty, guys.
Future'sTrader71, he's the truth.
He's a good mentor.
He really actually, a lot like myself.
I believe he really wants people to,
he's a real trader.
All right, guys, I'll see you guys
tomorrow at the study session.
Of course, always, man.
All righty, guys.
Good Friday, and I'll see you guys in charts.
You're welcome.